today's video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platforms
built a beautiful website
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in just a bit
on september 9 1976 chinese dictator mao
zedong breathed his last in beijing
signaling the end of an era outside
china was in chaos still reeling from
the terror of the cultural revolution
cut off from the rest of the world 88 of
its people were living in extreme
poverty it was a wounded monochromatic
peasant society encompassing nearly a
quarter of the planet's population yet
within a single generation this
oversized gulag would find itself
transformed from a damaged backwood
society china would be catapulted into
one of the greatest economic booms in
human history transformed almost
overnight into a superpower that by 2010
could claim the second largest economy
on earth the reason for this planet
shaking change the rise of deng xiaoping
a tiny uncharismatic man with a long
history as a loyal communist there was
nothing on dung's resume to suggest that
it'd be capable of reversing china's
fortunes indeed at the time he took
power he was already in his mid 70s yet
somehow this unpromising old man would
wind up becoming perhaps the most
important leader
in modern world history reformist
authoritarian dictator visionary this is
the story of deng xiaoping the man who
made china great again
when deng xiaoping was born in sichuan
on august 22nd 1904 it was into a china
that was less than a decade away from
collapse decades of misery under the
decaying ching dynasty had left the
empire as a shell of its former self
devastated by internal rebellions
humiliated by foreign powers in short it
was a country ripe for revolution not
that the young dung would be involved by
the time the chinese revolution broke
out in 1911 toppling the last emperor
dung was only just starting elementary
school then it's got to be said it's not
like his family were doing badly out of
the imperial system as is so often the
case the future communist came from a
solidly middle class family his father
was a landlord the richest man in their
village in fact dad was so comparatively
wealthy that in 1919 he was able to
arrange for his son at the time known as
den xi-jian to leave china to study in
france and it was the perfect time to
get out following a period of
authoritarian rule post-revolution china
had collapsed into something known as
the warlord era the time of chaos where
local strong men carved out dubious
statelets with bullets so backing his
son off to eat some crossovers and
absorb la culture francais probably
seemed like a spiffing idea to dung's
dad in reality though the teenager would
absorb something else in europe a taste
for revolution dung arrived in france in
late 1920 aged 16 and not really knowing
what to expect what he got was a country
thrumming with tension as the fallout
from the 1917 russian revolution
inspired marxists across the continent
including in the heart of dung's
workplace
yes work while the program the boy was
on was supposed to expose him to the
enlightened values of france in reality
it exposed him to life at the sharp and
pointy end of capitalism forced to slave
away in dark evil factories for less
than a pittance dung quickly fell under
the sway of an older radical named zhou
en lai together they became members of
the communist party a reaction to the
squalor and filth that they saw around
them but dung wouldn't leave completely
unimpressed with europe while he
despised the exploitation he also
marveled at the technology that allowed
this continent of empires to dominate
the globe that gave it not just great
wealth but power when he finally rose to
the top it would be these memories that
would help dung reshape china but first
he had to get back there in 1926 a
french arrest warrant sordong flee lara
public for the icy embrace of soviet
moscow there he was given military
training joining the communist
international and he married a fellow
budding revolutionary zhang shiwan then
it was back to china to ferment
revolution or so went the plan instead
dung set foot back in his home country
just as it veered hard to the right 1927
saw the nationalist komentang under
chiang kai-shek end the warlord era and
reunite china by beating everybody else
into a bloody pulp in that crazy violent
age dung was thrown into a life of
adventure changing his name to deng
xiaoping he surfaced in wuhan where he
first met a fellow revolutionary named
mao zedong in shanghai where street
battles and assassinations were the
order of the day in guangxi where he
helped instigate worker riots in a weird
way this must have been a romantic time
like living the plot of some adventure
novel yet of course real life is never
quite as enjoyable as fiction as the
1930s dawned and chiang kai-shek
consolidated power the remaining
warlords and communists were stamped out
one by one dung's small force was
destroyed during an offensive at
guangzhou around the same time his wife
died up to his neck in revolution dung
missed the funeral finally in 1931 the
widowed 26 year old was forced to flee
to escape into friendly territory under
the control of his comrade mao zedong it
was here that dung would soon forge the
relationship which would transform not
just his life but the lives of everyone
in china
deng xiaoping arrived in mao's
mountainous statelet just as a power
struggle between mao and other party
bosses was boiling over a struggle in
which everybody had to choose a side the
side dung chose the one marching under
the banner of mao's serene balding head
while it would cost him politically in
the short term it would eventually turn
out to be
a bit of an excellent choice now all
dong had to do was survive long enough
to see the benefits and trust me this
was going to be no easy task in october
of 1933 chiang kai-shek decided to crush
the rebel scum once and for all a
million komingtang forces surrounded
mao's zhang shi base faced with superior
numbers the communists did the only
thing they could they retreated bolting
for the far-off safety of shanxi so
began one of the most storied moments in
chinese history the long march was a
retreat that more than lived up to its
name covering nearly ten thousand
kilometers or six thousand miles it saw
seventy thousand communists battle
across dangerous terrain suffering so
much from exposure and attacks that only
ten thousand survived deng xiaoping
nearly wasn't among their number always
small and scrawny dung was brutally
exhausted by the march an exhaustion
that nearly became fatal when he
contracted typhoid fever yet by some
miracle dung made it reaching yanan
alongside mao and from there marching
into the pages of history it was the
long march that finally decided the
power struggle in mao's favor that
turned down into one of his most trusted
lieutenants but if the younger man
thought his hardships were over he would
soon be sorely disappointed next few
years were like a churning rolling sea
of different currents all sweeping
together to create a tsunami of change
that would soon transform china there
was the brutal flood coming from japan
as the imperial army invaded in 1937
kicking off the second sino-japanese war
there was the counter-current of
resistance as chiang kai-shek was forced
to make peace with the communists to try
and repel the invaders and through it
all there was the undertow of the civil
war pushed below the surface in the
existential emergency but far from
forgotten in short it was a crazy time
one that could make an entire video in
and of itself a time that saw communist
party membership leap from mere
thousands to 1.2 million that sawdung
placed in charge of vast military forces
a time that also saw down meet physics
student zhaolin who'd become his wife
and stay by his side until his death
sadly though it's not a time that we can
go into any depth today not unless we
want the entire post-war period of
dung's life just to be summed up by me
going and then he did a load of other
important [ __ ] and died the end so for
today all you need to know is that
number one major history spoiler japan
lost the war and number two chiang
kai-shek then managed to somehow lose
the chinese civil war and now we can
rejoin our narrative on the 1st of
october 1949 as a battle hard and dang
xiaoping watches mao triumphantly
proclaim the people's republic of china
for dung this must have been the high
point of his life the final realization
of all those socialist dreams that it
dreamed decades ago in the miserable
factories of france but there was little
time to savor it because mao almost
instantly dispatched him to defeat
remaining nationalist forces in the
southwest and oversee the annexation of
tibet a job done carried out with such
brutal efficiency that even mao was like
damn son
that's a lot of dead people over there
finally though dung was able to return
to beijing his head held high to claim
his reward working once again with his
old friend from his europe day xiao
enlai now china's premiere dung became
finance minister by 1956 he'd been named
secretary-general of the communist party
on a visit to moscow the next year mao
pointed dung out to nikita khrushchev
saying do you see that little man over
there he is very intelligent and has a
great future ahead of him since we're
bothering to make a video on him you
already know mal was right dung really
did have a great future ahead of him but
first he was going to have to
concentrate on survival because china
was about to embark on two decades of
non-stop catastrophe and by the time it
was over nearly all dung's comrades
would be purged dead
or both
now just before we get on with the rest
of today's video let me interrupt it for
a quick word from today's fantastic
video sponsor squarespace now more than
ever people are getting creative with
their time reaching deep into their
savings account to start that new
business or launch a blog where they
share their opinions with friends and
neighbors the world is yours and
squarespace is the platform to use when
you're ready to get started on that web
project that you've been thinking about
are you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website should look like bam use
one of their quick beautiful templates
to make a website that's fresh and for
you like it's right out of the box or
maybe you're more of a hands-on person
you've got lots of opinions and ideas
about what exactly your site should look
like well squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about and once
you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing around
with the colors there's a ton of extra
features that squarespace give you so
your website can succeed patronage
portals email campaigns social
integrations member only areas analytics
customer support commercial options it's
everything you could ever need in one
place so when you're ready to get
started on the next project of yours big
or small if it involves a website it's
got to be with squarespace right now you
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
next website or domain and now back to
today's video
[Music]
in terms of drawing the short straw of
eras to live in it's hard to imagine a
straw shorter than the one marked china
1957-1977
that's because those two decades were so
chaotic so horrific for many that make
living through the pandemic era look
like a sunday school picnic not that
dung would have had any reason to feel
insecure as this turbulent here adorned
by 1957 it used his position to build a
vast power network within the communist
party that same year it also scored
points with mao by directing the
anti-rightist campaign a witch hunt that
was meant to root out
counter-revolutionaries but instead saw
550 000 mostly innocent intellectuals
purged humiliated in struggle sessions
and forced into hard labor but what did
1957 era done care if he ruined a few
innocent lives he hadn't yet felt the
horrors of persecution himself hadn't
yet suffered as his victims had and what
better way to curry mao's favor than to
keep funneling suspected enemies into
prison camps nasty as it was though the
anti-rightist campaign was just the
starter the murderest dim sum before the
main course the first of those two
bloody manes the great leap forward
perhaps the greatest act of economic
self-harm in history the great leap
forward saw mao try to outdo stalin's
five-year plans by forcing peasants into
collective farms controlled by the party
their people were forced to meet
impossible quotas before they could eat
since these quotas were you know
impossible millions upon millions of
people starved in what became the
greatest famine in human history while
the wild claims you see online that a
hundred million died are about as
historically rigorous as the time travel
sections in bill and ted most serious
scholars place the death toll at around
45 million that's like the entire
population of argentina all dying in a
few years it's an utterly insane number
of casualties it seems to have also been
the moment that dunn got cold feet with
maoism at first the loyal lieutenant
simply applauded as the great leap got
underway fully supporting the changes
that would lead to such an immense
tragedy but as the horrors became more
and more evident he seems to have
hesitated maybe his conscience was
pricked maybe he just realized that
starving the entire country to death
wasn't a super great way of shoring up
communist support whatever the reason
this was the point that dung began to
pivot from a mao disciple to a moderate
at least
moderate in the context of the ccp this
meant joining the faction that in 1962
managed to sideline mao after the great
leap ended even forcing the chairman to
engage in the humiliating self-criticism
at the 7000 cadres conference in the
aftermath it looked like mao would be
forced to take a back seat that dung the
moderates would be able to take china
away from his turbocharged stalinism and
into something more like the ussr under
khrushchev but this is chairman mao
we're talking about a guy whose sheer
ruthlessness was matched only by his
overwhelming vanity it would be mao's
revenge on the moderates who humiliated
him that made up the second course of
our depressing metaphorical meal
launched in 1966 the cultural revolution
is another thing that we could easily
spend an entire video on and still not
do justice to but the basic version is
that mao encouraged the rank-and-file to
rise up against the party's elite to
bombard the headquarters and sweep away
all monsters and demons the result was
anarchy in the cities as teenage red
guards subjected teachers and officials
to deadly struggle sessions and people
were humiliated or murdered for the
slightest ideological deviations as it
became clear what was happening dung
desperately tried to pivot back to mao
to save his own skin by making public
denunciations of comrades but mao never
forgot a slight and it now makes sure
dung suffered just as badly as the
victims of the anti-rightist campaign in
1967 red guards trashed his home
declaring in the nation's number two
capitalist rhoda shortly after he was
forced to make a damning self-criticism
purge from the party and dispatched a
toilet misery building tractors out in
the countryside but the purge didn't
stop with dung himself his younger
brother was driven to suicide by the red
guards his son was tortured leaving the
boy paralyzed yet incredibly this
wouldn't be the end of deng xiaoping
purged or not dung would not just
survive the cultural revolution but make
it back into the corridors of power and
when he finally returned it would be
with a plan to rise to the very top
[Music]
perhaps the craziest thing about dung's
political survival is that he was purged
not once but twice his old buddy zhou
and lai helped shield him from the worst
the first time and in 1973 he was
quietly recalled to beijing but then
zhou died at the beginning of 1976
kicking off a wave of popular protest in
support of zhao's memory and against the
excesses of the cultural revolution
rather than be all like maybe it's a
good time to uh reflect and stop all of
the bloodshed the party elites blamed
dung for the protests and he was purged
all over again this is the point where
we opened our video with china
effectively in ruins its economy a
dumpster fire and dung xiaoping under
house arrest yet within two years and
three months of bal's death that
september dung would go from capitalist
rhoda to the nation's paramount leader
the wheel started turning before mao's
corpse was even cold after the chairman
died the gang of four behind so much of
the cultural revolution was arrested
that done dung's allies started pressing
the new leader hua gual feng to
rehabilitate him although he was mao's
handpicked successor i didn't have much
of a power base so he did that over
releasing dung perhaps sensing that he
might prove more popular than him but in
the end he was forced to relent during
the years before the upheavals dung had
assiduously cultivated allies in all
parts of the party now with the threat
of denunciation receding those allies
were coming out of the woodwork pressing
hua to give this old man another chance
at last quark wave dung was released and
brought back into the fold at that
moment the death warrant was signed on
huaquah thing's premiership although hua
tried to hold on to protect himself as a
leader the reality is that dung simply
had more allies more skill at playing
political games slowly he sidelined his
rival just as his once sidelined mao
like the proverbial frog that doesn't
realize the water is boiling hwa didn't
notice that he was sliding into
obscurity until it was too late by the
time of the third plenum of the 11th
central committee in december 1978 dung
and his allies were effectively in
charge that meant that on the 18th dung
was able to open a dull sounding meeting
that would turn out to be one of the
most consequential events in modern
world history just as khrushchev's
secret speech in 1956 had broken the
ussr with its stalinist past so too
would this meeting break china away from
the nightmares of maoism unlike
khrushchev though dung would never
publicly denounce his old mentor beyond
a careful declaration in 1981 that mao
had been 70 right and 30 wrong but the
impact would still be immense it was at
this meeting that dung and his allies
decided to open up their nation not just
politically but to market forces known
as reform and opening it would soon
transform the middle kingdom from a
basket case into one of the most
powerful nations on earth
[Music]
at the moment dung emerged on the
international stage as china's leader it
was assumed that it'd be a transitional
figure remember by now dung is in his
mid 70s even with the best will in the
world people assumed that he'd soon
shuffle off to the great khadra
conference in the sky instead dung would
wind up ruling either openly or behind
the scenes for 18 years 18 years that
were among the most transformative in
chinese history his key early move was
to end communal land and return to a
system of private ownership out in the
countryside this meant breaking up the
state-run farms allowing peasant
families to divide plots of land for
their personal use now to be fair this
had already been happening the damage of
the cultural revolution had been so
great that the peasants had been forced
to return to small holdings to simply
survive but dung didn't just allow the
process to unfold he accelerated it at
the same time as owning land was
legalized so too were markets private
enterprise was officially allowed what
followed was a leap in living standards
suddenly the peasants were starting to
turn a profit profits they invested into
expanding their farms or building new
homes creating a construction boom nor
was it just the peasants in some of the
coastal cities dung instituted special
economic zones to attract overseas
manufacturers bringing industry and
profit in all things that the communists
professed to loathe but then that was
deng xiaoping having seen the horrors of
rigid ideology he now only wanted
whatever worked as he memorably said of
market reforms it doesn't matter whether
a cat is black or white as long as it
catches mice and in china's case that
cat would soon catch so many mice it'd
be as gorged and bloated as post lasagna
garfield suffering from a thyroid
problem progress was so staggering you
could see it from day to day in the
special economic zone of shenzhen for
example a 1980 population of 58 000
ballooned to over 2 million by 1990 then
over 5 million by 1997 as the special
zones multiplied manufacturing spikes
leading to a surge of exports at the
same time the transformation of china's
cities saw a profound shift in how
people lived when dung took power
china's countryside was essentially as
it had been for centuries an
agricultural economy in which the vast
majority of the population lived in
poverty by the mid-1980s though industry
and services had outstripped farming as
people poured into the glowing cities
seeking a quality of life that had
recently been just unthinkable speaking
of poverty when mao died 88 of china's
vast population had lived on under two
dollars a day by 1986 the reforms had
seen that drop to around 60 percent by
the time dung died in 1997 the figure
would have plummeted to just over 40
percent a boost in living standards for
hundreds of millions of people nor was
it just living standards that saw china
change or the explosion of wealth summed
up by dung's very unsocialist phrase to
get rich is glorious no it was things
like the army being made to serve the
economy rather than the other way around
the sudden proliferation of
multinational corporations doing
business on chinese soil the
transformation of shanghai into a global
financial hub but before we get too
carried away we should probably make one
thing very clear this wasn't some
capitalist fairy tale while dung was
fine with ordinary people profiting off
china's transformation there was one
thing that he would never allow to take
hold in china democracy in the great
chaos that flowed through the mao era
dung had seen a warning yes against
personality cults but also against
allowing any thoughts which might
destabilize society if all one billion
of us undertake multi-party elections he
once explained we will certainly run
into a full-scale civil war taking
precedence over all china's problems is
stability sadly that commitment to
stability at all costs would soon lead
to unimaginable tragedy
[Music]
by the late 1980s china was riding a
wave of optimism likely not seen since
before the opium wars under dung the ccp
had negotiated a return of hong kong and
macau under a one country two systems
rule designed to help maintain their
autonomy the nation was also pursuing a
policy of keeping the peace with its
neighbors dropping belligerents in favor
of quietly focusing on economic growth
oh sure things weren't all rosy there
was rampant corruption among the party
elites the expansion of industry had
seen eye-watering levels of pollution
and the demographic disaster that was
the one child policy was well underway
but for most of china's billion-plus
citizens life was improving and that led
plenty to wonder if things couldn't
improve even more you can probably
already guess the answer that in april
1989 the death of the ccp's great
liberalizer hu yao bang recently booted
out of the party saw students flood
tiananmen square to mark his passing
there their raw energy combined with
anger over the recent price fluctuations
to become a great cry for change demand
for democracy at first hopes were high
after all dung had flirted with the
democracy movement before early in his
reign perhaps this million-strong
protest would convince him to pass
reforms but that was a serious
misreading of deng xiaoping he may have
been a reformer but he was also an
authoritarian with a history of
persecuting others and in summer of 1989
it was the authoritarian side that won
out on the 4th of june the people's
liberation army attacked tiananmen
square with military-grade weaponry and
tanks the fighting that followed saw
anywhere between 210 000 mostly unarmed
demonstrators killed countless more were
arrested or disappeared to this day
there has been no reckoning in china
over the massacre all we know is that it
was a bloodbath and that it couldn't
have happened without dung's blessing
not long after the violence in beijing
dung resigned his posts within the party
handing power over to his hand-picked
successor jiang zemin but this was only
a nominal change behind the scenes dung
continued to direct all major decisions
keeping an iron grip on power and thanks
to this he was able to ensure his vision
of china survived it's easy to forget
now but there was a ton of speculation
when dung stepped down that his exit
might spark a power struggle a return to
hardline communism or even a civil war
but because dung relinquished his grasp
so slowly
this never had a chance to happen from
1989 to 1997 the country was eased into
life under jiang zemen even as dung
still refined his plan for socialism
with chinese characteristics when the
soviet union collapsed in 1991 it only
solidified his belief that the party's
source of legitimacy was its expanding
economy the very next year now nearly 90
he went on a tour of the country pushing
ahead the reform process exhorting china
to open up still further he even
conducted one final purge ridding the
party of its hardliners thereby ensuring
this brave new china would survive his
death that death eventually came on the
19th of february 1997 by then he was 92
crippled by parkinson's unable to walk
or even feed himself unlike mao though
as he breathed his last it wasn't at the
heart of a country torn apart by chaos
but inside the capital of a newly
confident nation on the cusp of becoming
a superpower today deng xiaoping's place
in chinese history is assured while not
all his successes have rigorously
followed his path not least regarding
beijing's attitude towards hong kong and
its neighbors no one to date has ever
thought of abandoning the opening up
that made the nation an economic giant
certainly the gains ushered in by dung's
reforms have been impressive today
extreme poverty has dropped to 0.5
percent of the chinese population at
change that has seen at least 800
million lives improve for the better
while some credit needs to go to post
deng premieres he was still the one who
set the tone for this had hwa gual
feng's leadership model won out back in
1978 china might still be a peasant
society filled with people in drab
matching uniforms a far cry from the
glamorous high-tech neon-drenched world
of today but of course there's more to
this story than just a rising tide of
prosperity for all his reforms improved
millions of lives deng xiaoping was
still an authoritarian an authoritarian
who crushed dissent on democracy as
ruthlessly as he embraced capitalism
light there's also no getting around the
fact that he was a key part in the
regime that plunged so many into poverty
under mao in the first place in the end
though whether you believe he was a hero
a villain or somewhere between the two
there is no doubt that dung succeeded in
doing what he set out to do and in doing
so he remade not just his home country
but the entirety of world politics he
made china
great again
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]